nothing can prepare you to speak on TV
in front of a billion people in 4,000
you know Hollywood bigwigs West Bank
story they made a list of all the people
I have to think and you're not you know
you'd want to go up there and think a
million people then I had a list of 47
names I mean well you have about 60
seconds to get up there and get off so
now I got to go through and take out
some of the names no one knows me so as
a short filmmaker I have to kind of give
some context to the two what I was
talking about and of course you got to
thank the right people
you got to thank your parents and then
the night before the ambassador to
Israel called me and said listen I just
want you to know that if your film wins
it might be the first time that a movie
about the conflict in Middle East that's
pro-peace has ever won and I want I hope
that maybe you'll say something about
the fact that there are still people in
Israel and in Palestine who want peace I
don't know who are hopeful that there's
a future so it's like insane pressure so
not only that and by the way my agents
telling me you got to be funny my father
gave me advice my father's from Israel
he gave me advice like go to the stage
do dig the award and you say I'm now
ready for a job and walk off the stage I
was like that I can't say that that's
ridiculous
I made a comedy musical about Israelis
and Palestinians that takes place
between two falafel stands in the West
Bank and it's movie about peace and
about hope and to be able to get this
award just goes to show that there's so
many other people out there who support
that notion that when it comes to the
situation between Israelis and
Palestinians hope is not hopeless and on
another note I know a lot of people in
America are probably watching and asking
what are the short films well a lot of
them were made by directors or trying to
get noticed and I think in a lot of ways
we represent the little guy because we
don't have big studios behind us or
big-name actors or a lot of times the
budgets we need and it relies on
perseverance and stick-to-itiveness and
hustle and a dedication and loyalty from
a cast and crew who are doing it for
pennies if not for nothing so I'd be
remiss if I were to take this word and
not thank my co-writer kimray my
producers pascal vidal za me kim ashley
Jordan Ravi Malhotra and my composer
you've all run and last but not least
the two people who never doubted me even
when I doubted myself my mother who's
here in the audience Cathy my father Dan
is watching I love you thank you
you